[Music]
welcome everyone to grandmaster's choice
I Am Woman Grandmaster Talia cantes and
today we're going to be talking about
the very exciting rounds today of uh
Tata steel tournament in W con um it's
been a it's been a very exciting
tournament it's usually one of my
favorite ones to follow from the year um
one of the most um Pres I ones in the
first uh three or four months of the
year so it's very exciting and at the
same time we're blessed today with a
with a very um explosive round so we're
going to have a little bit of a recap of
the of the event and some of the games
that I thought were the most the most
interesting uh just as kind of a kind of
an overview I think today we're going to
be focusing more on the games between
nbe Abdu satov against Jordan B Forest
uh as well as um the game from param and
Max wadam um and then if we have a
little bit of time maybe we'll also take
a look at way against neoni but overall
it's been a very exciting event um I
believe some of the previous uh big
moments of the tournament where um
Prague defeating uh ding Len our current
world champion to become number one
player of India which is a huge
achievement uh as well as J and June
defeating uh um ala Feria who I believe
is her highest rated win uh so yeah lots
of exciting little things in this
tournament and today is not really an
exception so uh the first game we're
going to be taking a look at today like
I said it's nobe against Jordan B forest
and the game started off with E4 E5
Knight F3 Knight C6 Bishop C4 very
standard Italian Knight to F6 no Knight
G5 we don't do that here D3
and D5 by Jordan B Forest this is a very
interesting choice um I would say that
you don't see it as often um nowadays it
can lead to a very dangerous position uh
because the center has opened up so
suddenly um and it kind of foreshadows
some of the some of the problems that
happen later for for Jordan uh the most
standard move in this position I would
say it's Bishop to C5 there's also
Bishop to E7 um very natural play uh but
D5 can end up leading to a lot of
complications due to after e takes D5
Knight takes D5 the center might not be
as stable and then black still needs a
few extra moves to Castle uh so the game
actually continue with castles Bishop to
E7 Rook to E1 already putting pressure
on the pawn on
E5 and it's not necessarily that white
is much better in this position it's
just a lot easier to play as white right
because all of the moves are coming in
very naturally the bishop on C4 tends to
be very dangerous in this e45 um
Italians and at the same time like I
said Knight on F3 already attacking on
E5 Rook attacking on E5 uh it's a little
difficult to to defend as as black and
then they actually ended up playing the
move Pawn to F6 right which is usually
not a move that you see in in this type
of openings like I said it could create
even more uh more problems in this
diagonal with the bishop on
C4 but um on the surface it just looks
um it just looks like a normal position
right if white wants to be better then
they're going to have to do some sort of
breakthrough in the center which is not
ready just
yet Bishop to B3 was playing in the game
uh very interesting move just retreating
the bishop uh kind of you know
stabilizing all of the pieces before
continuing and uh van fores decides to
play with with Pawn to A5 right which is
a novelty in this position uh it's kind
of an unexpected uh unexpected move the
idea obviously is to gain space and also
have the threat of Pawn 2 A4 um but at
the same time as we were mentioning
earlier uh one of the biggest things
that you really need to do in the
opening is get your pieces out make sure
that your king is getting to safety and
it doesn't really look like A5 is
cooperating with those ideas right um so
after Pawn to A5 Pawn to C3 was played
Knight to
B6 and now we are getting to a very
interesting position um Knight to H4 was
played and even though this is not the
best move in the position it's very
interesting how Norbeck with the white
pieces the initiative in this position
is trying to provoke weaknesses in
Black's territory right because the move
Knight to H4 comes with what
threat Queen H5 yeah Queen H5 is coming
and then it's very difficult actually to
to do something about it right so if
you're playing as black in this position
probably the most natural continuation
would be G6 which is what was playing in
the game although interestingly
enough um it is possible to play the
move Queen to D7 it looks very strange
but it's actually surprisingly okay for
for black queen to D7 Queen to H5 you
don't play G6 because Knight takes G6
but instead you can actually go King to
d8 uh escaping the the threats and then
now there's actually the idea of Queen
to G4 coming up and then if black
manages to trade the Queens then somehow
the you know the King on d8 has no
problems at all right it's still very
unclear but Queen to D7 is a move that
could have been played although it's
very unnatural I would say right not
only because you're allowing Queen to H5
but also you're putting the queen right
in front of the bishop that hasn't
developed so it's it's a very difficult
move to make right right much more
natural is the move that was played in
the game which is G6 as I was mentioning
but at the same time this move creates a
lot of weaknesses right and again for
the past few moves uh we have seen uh
the moves Pawn 2 A5 uh Knight to B6 Pawn
to G6 from uh from black so it's not
super clear how they're making progress
in the position right um and then sooner
or later more well more soon than later
uh the break Pawn to D4 is going to come
opening up the E file and then black is
going to be under a lot of pressure
right so uh in this position after G6
white wants to ensure that the bishop
stays in the long diagonal this is a
very common idea of the of the Italian
and sometimes the Spanish as well um
regardless of how specific this opening
was so the move Pawn to A4 was played
and then now white has a very clear
advantage in this position because
because they pretty much have no
weaknesses nothing is going to challenge
this bishop on B3 like black is not
going to be able to Castle short um at
any point so they're going to have to
come up with a different
idea D4 is still uh a big problem right
uh this bishop can develop to E3 to H6
that's also another possibility and you
know overall all of the white pieces
will keep on finding their footing
meanwhile for black it's not so clear
what to do
right Bishop to D6 was played oh and I
should mention as well that it was
actually van forest with the black
pieces who was burning down a lot of
time on the clock uh which is very
unusual because uh you know I was me as
was mentioning the broadcast with um
Daniel nitzki and David Howell van fores
is a very creative player and a lot of
times when you see him play you see him
you know as a top player of course uh
being into some very deep preparation uh
playing quickly and a lot of times he
finds like this offbeat variations or
maybe some Pawn sacrifices in the
openings to get some sort of initiative
going but here it just looks like his
position is very uncomfortable and
things are not going right for him right
and once you you know as a player once
you get to those type of positions it's
really difficult to to get back up right
Bishop to D6 was played and then now
what would be the most natural move here
for
white
D4 uh D4 yeah D4 is the move that was
played and it makes a lot of sense right
um if we are playing in this position
against the lag of development the black
has it makes sense that we play Fast
right like we need to have some sort of
break through quickly utilize the fact
that the king is in the center that the
pieces are not developed and then you
know do something before black manages
to coordinate themselves so D4 was
played Queen to
E7 uh perhaps with the idea of getting
the bishop out of the way Bishop to D7
in the future in Long
Castle Bishop to E3 was played another
possible move would have been Bishop to
H6 both of them are kind of okay uh
Bishop to to H6 I would say makes uh a
little bit more sense controlling more
of the position and keeping the E file
more open but Bishop to E3 Bishop to D7
but B E3 got a it got
a question mark from the computer during
the the broadcast do you remember
that uh yeah so Bishop 2 E3 in this
position I mean it's uh it's diff
difficult to to say that it's a bad move
because it's a developing move right
like how how bad can it be I would say
dubious at at worse
um in general yes maybe bishop 2 H6 was
you know a little bit better just a
better spot for the for the bishop in
general um Bishop 2 E3 the the
interesting thing about it maybe
something that no noticed that might be
useful for the future um is that later
on when the position opens up a little
bit uh maybe something like d takes E5
there are always ideas of Bishop takes
B6 which uh can also become you know can
can create a lot a lot of weaknesses on
the king side on the queen side if black
decides to Castle along so I believe
that was part of the idea of this move
uh but yeah Bishop to H6 would have been
a little bit a little bit more
precise still the position is a lot more
comfortable for white um and they do
have the the advantage and the
initiative here because it's still very
uncomfortable
to to find your footing here as
black um yeah and the game actually
continued with Bishop to D7 and then
here D takes E5 F takes E5 and Knight to
F3 the Knight did its job on H4 it
provoked some weaknesses now it's
getting back into the game uh it's going
to put some pressure on to E5 in the
future and at the same time with the
Knight going back uh you know even
though it's a retreating move it still
makes a lot of threats because for
example the king cannot cast so long
right now because
of because of
what
B G5 yeah Bishop to G5 right and then
with the help of the Knight there is
this um this threat right to to gain
some
material so Knight to
F3 black actually played Pawn to H6
because they still want to Castle along
um and then white decides to finish the
development with Knight
bd2 and the Knight coming to D2 is not
only a a developing move but at the same
time the Knight is going to E4 right and
this Square will kind of work as an
outpost for the Knight because it's
going to be nearly impossible to to get
it kicked out of there and at the same
time it still puts a lot of pressure
onto onto the black
pieces long Castle was played Knight to
E4 Bishop to F5 and then how do we keep
our um how do we keep keep our
domination in the
position like should should we Retreat
or can we do something something
else
obviously our Knight on e4 looks really
good there right we wouldn't want to to
lose that square so how can we
reinforce Bishop
C2 um I would say Bishop to C2 is is a
possibility but is it the bishop that
you want on on e4 or is it on another
piece
knight2 yeah Knight fd2 right this is
the move that another Buck played and it
makes a lot of sense again like the
Knight on e4 is such a great piece it
controls all over the the board it puts
a lot of pressure onto this bishop um
the ideas of Bishop takes B6 are still
kind of in the air and overall it just
makes uh makes a lot of sense right the
bishop coming to C2 I think it's fine uh
at some point this bishop will have to
find a better Square than B3 which is
kind of what happened in the game but it
is the Knight what the piece that we
want on e4 so Knight F D2 was played and
you don't really need to be worried
about you know something in this file if
Bishop takes Knight takes there is not
really a good square that this bishop
can go to um if Bishop to C5 to have
some sort of Discovery you even have
Bishop takes C5 attacking the queen back
so it's completely
fine and you know any square like B4 A3
doesn't really make any sense so um even
though black has a bishop it's not like
they can freely move it anywhere and
this is not a not a big threat the two
knights don't have many squares to move
to either white just got the pair of
Bishops the position is completely fine
yeah so after Knight of
D2 black actually played with Knight to
D7 trying to regroup the Knight somehow
either to C5 or to B6 but overall it is
quite difficult to make progress and
with every move that black makes uh
there is a there's a new week square or
like a new weakness left behind right
and we were just mentioning how this
bishop would like a better Square which
would also allow white to consider the
possibility of B4 right and finally
having a breakthrough on the king side
so what could be the square that we
want D5 yeah Bishop to
D5 I saw your message
too um yeah so Bishop to D5 right the
Knight on B6 no longer controls the
square black is moving backwards so we
got to move forward right and there are
going to be um more threats right of
Bishop takes C6 weakening all over the
the queen side maybe something like
Bishop C6 Queen to E2 is coming and the
queen can get into H6 and overall it's
very difficult to to defend right um so
for example after Bishop to D5 Knight to
C5 was
played and now getting you know the last
of the pieces involved Queen to E2 Queen
to B5 is coming and this is going to be
a very dangerous move there are threats
on um threats on C5 C6 A5 maybe even B
B7 in the future uh things have clearly
gone very very wrong
for for black and then while you're
watching the game you know clearly it
looks like white is
better uh but at the same time well I
don't know about this exact position but
at the same time the evaluation is
something like plus three and then
you're wondering how is it how is it
possible that it's such a such a huge
Vantage but if you just look at the
position white doesn't have any weakness
there's nothing that that black can
Target we do have the Kings on opposite
sides and that usually means that there
is um a rise in the attack right like
one side is trying to reach the
opponent's king faster than the other uh
but here like the white king is
completely safe there is no danger this
bishop would have a nice diagonal but
it's blocked by the opponent on E5 and
this one will not move ever again
because of the Knight on
e4 uh these two knights have not found
their you know their good Square just
yet uh White just uh created the
possibility to play with B4 the queen on
E2 just incorporated into the game it
can get into B5 there's again the threat
of something like Bishop takes C6 taking
on C5 and uh Queen to A6 there's just
way too much going on
going on here on White's favor right and
there's a lot of control over the light
squares as
well like C4 E4 B5 for example right uh
no peace is under any big danger uh the
Knight on e4 is well supported by both
the other Knight and the bishop um and
this kind of also ties back to earlier
in the game where black decided to play
with Pawn to A5 right instead of
finishing off the development a A5 A4
favors WI a lot like I said B5 is very
weak and overall it's quite difficult
to to make any sort of progress or
create counterplay as black right
um it's really difficult to find any
counterplay here on the king side for
black I would say um for a move like you
know let's
say
um well you can't really play Queen to
A4 because C5 is hanging but let's say
something like Knight takes Knight takes
Queen to
H4 there's not really there's not really
any threat because you can always play
something like G3 right and things are
fine um you can even you can probably
even like
allow you know allow black to take with
a move
like I don't know maybe even a move
like Rook D1 just just to mention it and
then after it takes you have G3 right
and then the queen can't defend E4 and
then you take it back again so even if
you give even if you give black an extra
move then um they don't even have a
concrete thread
right however the way that black played
kind of made it easier for for white to
keep going because again there was
really no uh no counterplay at all and
at the same time it is Jordan with the
black pieces who's burning down a lot of
time uh White is just naturally making
moves everything looks very intuitive
very natural um and not spending much
time Knight to B8 was
played and then the move Rook ad D1 um
another possible move would have been F3
but overall the position is just very
very easy to play play as white almost
any move does the
job Rook a D1 and now Knight to A6
trying to reinforce this Knight on C5
and then maybe in the future have the
idea of taking on e4 and then bringing
this Knight over to C5 because as we
know exchanges tend to favor um you know
the side that's under a lot of
pressure so in this position what would
be the the most accurate continuation
for
white like I said almost any move is is
good in the position like
this um but how can we keep incrementing
our
pressure and at the same time maybe it's
not visible right now but you also have
to take into account that the fact these
two knights are like binded together
right so if you kick take one of them
away the other the other one becomes
really compromised right so this can
become a an issue in the future
too uh like move the B Pawn Yeah
B4 um yeah I think probably B4 is a
possibility I would be a little bit
worried to go for it right away because
I'm not sure if after something like
takes takes it you know probably like
the position is still um much better
for much better for white but I would
say maybe after takes takes night
takes you know you you would really have
to to calculate it well until the end
because this bishop is hanging and then
we don't want to give black any extra
any extra
chances Maybe we can make a few moves
first and then prepare
before
any other
ideas if the knights are binded to one
another and if we know that if we attack
one of them the other one is compromised
we don't really want to give them the
chance to to move away right like get
traded for one of our pieces so what can
we I got I got a call just at this point
in the game so I don't remember what was
played what is calling me
is Bishop takes
B7 Bishop takes B7 that's that's very
creative move obviously if Knight takes
there's Queen takes
A6 right um and then if King
takes yeah Queen to
B5 the question is Yeah question
is I mean he's got three guarding the
Knight on
C5 right he only got three attacking
it
um I have the feeling that there must be
I I would like to believe that there is
something in this position
um but it's a little bit
unclear
the thing is that for example if you
make a move like
B4 which I think would be nice right
because if Knight takes and you have
time for Queen A6 yeah um
Perhaps Perhaps there is something
like
well I was going to say Bishop D7 but
then there's Queen
A5 h
okay I would like to believe that this
works
somehow okay maybe we can
try oh maybe maybe we can do something
like takes
takes
this is looking bad for black it is
yeah okay I would say maybe bishop
D7 Queen
[Music]
here but this still doesn't look well
doesn't look very
good yeah this might
be this might be another continuation I
mean with Bishop to D7 before you playen
A5 what about takes B
check
Knight
takes well if Knight takes maybe
[Music]
now well if I take with the queen then
there's Pawn takes right right so I'm
forced to take with the pawn and then
you take with the
pawn PA takes but then the Queen the
queen is hanging the queen is still
hanging um
yeah well here I I mean here you would
have Queen
to6 what is he going to do after Queen
to
B6 no I think yeah Queen to
B6 I would say that there is more than
enough compensation here for for white
at the same time I don't know how
necessary it is to to
sack but okay
[Music]
maybe bishop takes B
seven he has to take with the king or
yeah yeah yeah he has to take with the
King for
sure and then I wonder if maybe there's
a more precise move than King to C8 King
to C8 is the one that seems the most
natural to
me um can you play King
A7 that's what I was thinking maybe King
A7 but I same time I don't like how
there's this spin going
on I don't see any way for maybe after
B4 something like takes takes
um
maybe Rook
here
yeah
it's getting
dicey
um maybe this I'm not sure because then
if Knight takes and Bishop
takes and I think somehow everything is
protected
um maybe King A7 is a little bit better
originally I thought maybe it was bad
because getting
the it's getting the the king to the the
diagonal
but maybe this is a maybe this is a
problem uh because then there is this
Rook to TOA if Knight B3 then the same
oh well Bish E4 is hanging but there's
also this um
so and what if he plays Knight takes
Knight immediately here yeah Knight
takes Bishop yeah Bishop
takes and now Knight
like you want to go Knight
B3 I mean no I was I was pluged that the
night on A6
yeah
um yeah maybe maybe now it's getting
more more difficult
yeah maybe King to A7 is the maybe it's
not so is the reputation
yeah yeah but that was Bishop B7 is a
very very nice move I hadn't thought
about
it
uh I would like to think that it works
somehow uh but at the same time almost
any move here
is is good for for white um the position
is is kind
of yeah like essentially black has no
counterplay and if black doesn't have
counterplay there is also no real need
for us to to complicate things if we
don't see the end of it if we do see
that the that the variation like fully
works then of course makes sense to go
for it but if we don't then at the same
time there's really no no risk in in
taking a few extra
moves so yeah maybe I don't know after
Bishop takes B7 King takes Queen B5 King
A7 it was difficult to to come up with a
with a
followup um but in the game Knight takes
D6 is what was played and after this it
was very simple the way that not back
converted the position um why because
again we're going to keep the two
knights intact and then we're going to
finally get our Knight into the game and
then start pressing with the idea of B4
right so Knight takes C takes D4 C takes
D6 um if he had taken with the queen or
with the Rook then there's Knight to C4
also with a with a
Tempo and then takes Knight to C4
anyways Queen to C7 and queen to D2 was
played and now this position is
[Music]
very very uncomfortable right there's
really no no way to to
continue the idea of B4 is
still still at large and
then you know it's just really
uncomfortable to get out of to to even
try and get out out of all of the
threats right
um yeah for example if Knight two Knight
to B3 which is a move that was
recommended in the Stream then there's
Knight to B6 right and then if Queen
takes B6 Bishop takes Knight takes D2 We
have Bishop takes d8 and then at the end
of all of the captures white ends up
being up in a change
right so there's no Knight B3 there's no
clear way for for black to to improve
their pieces um if for example if Knight
to D7 then there's a possibility of
Knight takes D6 as well because if Queen
takes Bishop takes
B7 um with this discover attack and
overall the position is just extremely
uncomfortable so actually yeah after
move
24 um van fores decided to resign with
the black pieces because the position is
just so so unbearable right and then I
mean we're looking at it from the white
side now if we flip the board just for
for a second um it it's hard to even
imagine what would be your next move
right because if you do anything that
you know that kind of seems like a
waiting move like I don't know Rook
here then there's this B4 threat right
and B4 is not only one threat it comes
with many more so it's very very hard to
to to make moves right uh not only the
Knight D6 idea or Knight B6 or Bishop B6
might be coming uh but overall it's just
too much too much pressure even B5 could
be a problem in the future and you know
the position is just like black is never
going to to recover so yeah it was a
very uh it was a very quick decisive win
for for n Beck with the white pieces
very convincing he's in the uh shared
lead now um I was kind of rooting for
him before the tournament
started so it's fun to fun to
see and yeah the game ended after Queen
to
D2 another game that I kind of wanted to
to briefly take a take a look at is the
game between Parham and
Max which I'm not going to show the
entire game I'm just going to show the
kind of the the end of it but it was was
a very it was a very exciting end to a
game at least it's something that I
don't I don't see very often I would see
more more of this type of end and ending
in a tournament like title Tuesday right
um rather than a classical event but we
have here this
position um for the majority of the game
uh Max waram was actually out playing
parhan with the black pieces he got a
very comfortable position out of the
open something like minus minus two um
and for majority of the game he was you
know on the driver's seat and even in
this position if you just kind of look
at it evaluate it for a moment um both
sides may have equal material but this
Pawn on A2 is extremely dangerous right
it is wi to move in this position um but
this position is very very dangerous you
know it's very different from Reading um
theoretical rugen games right like you
may read and you know how to do the
filor uh defense but then you find
yourself into this position in any game
and then how is that how is that helpful
at all right um so we have a very
particular end game
here um and a lot of a lot of the
question also comes from you know uh
which Pawn is faster right like the pawn
on A2 or the pawn on E5 that you know
like I said it's wide to move just move
to a to E6 right so so there's a
question of uh which Pawn is faster and
at the same time there is the question
of which piece is better is it the
bishop or is it the Knight right in
general for end games where there are
pawns on both sides of on both flanks
the bishop tends to be a little bit
better uh because it can switch from one
side of the board to the other quickly
right although here it's clearly more
about pure calculation then you know
just kind of evaluating the end game
itself right so after the move Pawn to
E6
clearly uh White also has dreams of
promoting the pawn in the future and if
we promote right now with Pawn to A1
then there's Rook to A8 right and then
there is a very nasty um skewer so I
just want to ask after Pawn to
E6 what would be the move that you play
here as black I can even flip the board
if you want so it's a little bit I don't
know if that makes it easier I'm a bit
confused
now but you know imagine your clock is
sticking down you're playing this
broadcaster tournament with a camera
staring at your face what would you do
here as black the pressure that you were
better the entire game and now you got
to prove
something what would you
do I like to see that we have uh in this
chat a lot of mixed
uh mixed Solutions but we'll discuss
them
soon it makes sense to block the to
block the the a file right so we kind of
have two options one is Rook to A3 the
other one is Bishop to A3 one is better
than the other the question is why right
um is there a reason why you chose
Bishop to
A3 uh I thought this was made decision
where Rook A3 was played in the game
okay all right that's
fair they show the B3 too yeah so yeah
Bishop to A3 is a little bit better than
Rook to A3 as we'll see although it is
kind of crazy because in this position
after Bishop to A3 um um at least you
know in my opinion it makes a lot of
sense uh because you're blocking with
the with the bishop rather than the Rook
The Rook can come to C1 um the bishop is
no longer under attack it's still
controls
E7 so there are a lot of um lots of
aspects in this um in this
position actually the best move here is
Rook to C3 according to the computer
computer um and it's kind of also also
very crazy Rook to C3 obviously the idea
is that if Rook takes Knight takes and
then you know at least we get to take
the pawn on
A2 and at the same time if the pawn
promotes to A1 then Rook takes
H3 and you know black is still winning
but they're going to have to be a little
bit precise um uh however after the move
like Queen to G1 it is you know it's
very easy to to get rid of all of the
threats E7 is not really something that
we are worrying about we can always give
up the bishop uh we have the threat of
Queen to G2 Queen to
G4 um and if something like Rook takes
A3 Ken takes and E7 trying to go with
the
pawn there is Queen to E1 Knight to E3
and you might think oh wow it's blocking
but thankfully there's is cheack on B
before right and somehow we're able to
finally get rid of the of the E Pawn
right um so Bishop to E3 would have been
a very very dangerous
uh very dangerous move uh however Rook
to A3 was played in the
game and you
know it's just so so crazy the way that
this game goes right because after Rook
to A3 Rook takes C5
Pawn promotes 2 A1 and then there is
E7 I'm going to flip it back to White
sorry uh Pawn goes to E7 and then I have
never had this type of type of endgame
in one of my games I don't think maybe
I've had I don't know I can't remember
all of my games but not at the at the
top of my head maybe this is something
that I would see on title Tuesday when
you're playing 3 minutes with one second
increment you know and then on one
second increment anything can happen
uh but it's actually very difficult
to it's actually very difficult to to
understand how to continue here and the
position is actually equal now after
Rook to A3 the this line with Rook C5
A1 um Bishop to E7 H sorry Pawn to E7
it's not so clear what to do now maybe
you guys recall the move that was play
in the game but um do you know what
would be the what would be a
continuation here for black you mean not
to
lose well yeah the position is equal
right now so right yeah right because
what he played was a
BL right which is very heartbreaking too
I must say
but imagine it was your game right and
you were playing you were playing five
six hours uh try trying to squeeze this
end game this other
2700 um with the black pieces you did
everything right in the opening you
outplayed him in the end game and now
you have to close of the game but things
are getting
messy
so can you try Queen
E1 Queen E1 is one of the
moves you can play Queen to E1 um and
then there's King to F5 kind of the the
only
move um yeah and then there's for
example Queen to B1 King into
F6 and it's not so clear but
somehow somehow this is this is okay
so it's difficult to to even understand
what's going on but this is one one way
to equalize another one is actually
Queen to
B1 uh King
to King to
E5 and then there is this uh Rook to D3
move which is kind of crazy as well you
can't play E8 because of queen to queen
to
E1 but actually there's Rook to C8 Queen
to E1 and there's only one move to draw
here I mean you don't have that many
options as as white but one move to
draw
looks like King to
D6 King to D6 I think after King to D6
the issue is that there's Rook
D5 King takes and queen
E7
so that's a big problem uh the king
coming to F5 obviously Rook D5 comes
with a check so actually the the only
move is King to F6 and then after Rook
takes D5 you promote and then all of a
sudden it's it's equality the best
recommendation is to trade queens and
then make a make a draw somehow so yeah
these positions are extremely extremely
sharp um who would have thought right
that after Rook to A3 this type of type
of End Game Wouldn't
rvel and after E7 I'm sure it was quite
difficult to to even you know understand
what was going on at the board
right uh because you might think okay I
have a queen on the board I should be
able to win and then all of a sudden
it's not super not super clear
um I am I am in a in a chess team and
I'm friends with a lot of grand Masters
sometimes I play Blitz with them and
then this is like the classic scenario
of me outplaying them the whole game and
then at the the end they have some
little trick uh like how white has here
and then I'm just so so amazed of what's
going on at the board and uh they end up
they end up uh swindling
me so that's what this type of game
reminds me of but yeah after Pawn to E7
uh Max actually played Queen to h8 which
is a a losing move
surprisingly
um you guys know why yeah
okay yeah because of Rook C8 so after
Rook
C8 somehow there's just nothing
that that black can do obviously if
Queen takes there's Knight B6 and then
it's a huge
issue and in the game Queen to H7 was
played but after
F5 uh Rook G3 E8 Rook takes G4 King
E5 L had to resign because they not only
down material but at the same time
there's Rook to A8 coming the position
is just terrible so it is crazy how I
don't know at least to me it's crazy how
the game just turned around and in a few
moves um I was watching a little bit of
the interview that Parham had after the
game and he seemed very very amazed he
was really going for a win in this game
and he was just outplayed from the
opening and he didn't think he had a
chance and then somehow things got
tricky at the end and he
finally uh this was his first win of the
tournament so that's very
exciting um and
yeah the the thing about being a chess
player is that you also get to
understand what when you know what it
feels like to lose a game and then when
you think about uh waram in this in this
game it's just um very sad and
unfortunate um you know especially
during a classical game when you put in
so much effort for for many many
hours but yeah it just goes on to show
like how difficult end games can be a
lot of people think that end games are
just you know trade pieces bring your
king to the center make a draw but you
can always have very sharp end games and
that's why it's also really good to
study practical end games as well
um well I wasn't really thinking of
giving recommendations but one book that
is kind of like J into my mind right now
is um a book called endgame voso I think
by Smith off or with examples from
smithl so it's uh it's a book that you
know I remember uh talks about like
different end games with let's say no
pawns or like Queen end games or like
different you know piecing balances and
it tends to be more on the Practical
side than the theoretical side like the
retki or or you know um
100 end games you must know so yeah it's
just a really just a mixture of
calculation understanding practical end
games and then uh try your best this
positions are very very difficult um
like I said I haven't had an endg game
like this in my own games but
uh but I've had to deal with like
complicated end games in the past and
it's always you know you're always
scared to make the wrong call and here
the definitely black made their wrong
call so yeah probably the highlight of
the round was this game and then really
quickly since we have um a little bit of
time I was very fascinated as well by
the game between wayi and Yan Pichi I
thought that it was very very
interesting um I think I'm just going to
briefly show the opening it was a
Bishop's opening which you also don't
see in top games a lot personally I
remember that when I was a kid I was
taught to play Queen 2 E2 in this
position and I played it a lot the idea
is to counteract any you know future
like D5 plan because you always have
takes and queen takes E5 um so you just
play naturally with Knight to F3 castles
um C3 kind of like typical Italian but
then you bring the Rook from F1 to D1
since you have the free Square play with
D3 or D4 defending depending on the
position and then the usual you know
Knight D2 Knight F1 Knight G3 but that's
a that's a topic for another day it's
not actually a good
opening D3 was played C6 Knight F3 black
actually had no problems uh absolutely
no problems out of the opening the
position was very standard we see this
E5 again but the situation of the of the
position is a lot different A4 Knight D7
castles castles Rook E1 um overall yeah
just the position makes a lot of sense
uh White Knight doesn't really have a
clear future and since the pawns were
traded and white is going to be the the
one putting pressure on the center
Knight to B1 was played with the idea of
going to C3 putting pressure on D5
there's also control over B5 maybe B5
D6 B6 was played Knight C3 Bishop B7
Knight B5 like I said Knight D6 is
coming queen to B8 and
D4 we're just getting a very very you
know
uh close position in the center but with
a lot of different Resources with a lot
of different resources uh White is
obviously going to play for C4 black has
a center with D5 and E4 uh but at the
same time they lack a good Bishop right
like if instead of the bishop being on
on uh B7 there was a bishop on
like well I would like to say like F4
but maybe that's a little bit
unrealistic maybe like C7 or D6 the
position might be might be
different but after Knight to D2 Bishop
C6 C4 takes takes Queen to
F4 uh G3 Queen F5 C takes D5 was played
and this is probably something that nepo
missed uh C takes D5 black is not able
to
recapture do you guys know
why
there is a tactic
here
PC uh
here yeah maybe I can play like Knight
Knight of6 or
something this is like a very specific
moment in the position it's kind of an
idea that you might miss uh at first
glance but then you
know it's it's attack G yeah G4 right
and then we're going after after this
Knight if Queen to uh Queen to
G5 I'm assuming you can probably take
but I was also just thinking about
H4 and then takes
takes um
and of course if the queen goes back to
E6 then there's Rook takes E4 and the
position is still under a lot of under a
lot of
pressure um so as we said black is not
able to take back on D5 so instead they
decided to play Rook ad d8 but now at
least white has a pawn even if it's
somewhat temporary it became permanent
but um it's uh it's a pawn now just that
that white has and what makes the
biggest difference in this position is
that the Knight on D7 doesn't have a
clear future right uh you could maybe be
a pawn down in this position but with
the Knight on D6 instead of D7 and the
position is um a lot more
holdable but okay e takes F3 Queen takes
Queen
G5 but now white G just very naturally
played the bishop on B3 got activity in
this diagonal kind of similar to to the
previous game and now King to f8 was
played which is a very interesting
choice it wants to get out of this out
of this diagonal obviously um and it
also had it was also preventing another
move but um we can still go on with our
idea
yeah as long as we were able to open up
the the position of the king
yeah six uh p7 yeah Rook A7 and our plan
is just to you know open up the position
around the king and also it frees up the
the square on D6 right because after it
takes takes
takes Rook to E1 was played which is
very natural but uh surprisingly Queen
to E2 was a little bit better the idea
is that when the King goes to to f8
Knight D6 uh there is also no
infiltration of like Queen D2 on like
what happened in the game with uh Rook
to E1 Knight D6 Queen D2 but even now
the white position is very comfortable
Queen to
C3 just getting to an end game uh G6
this Pawn on
F7 it's under attack forever pretty much
H3 not even capturing it at the moment
A4 and there's really no need to um to
get the bishop away from from its best
diagonal uh the pawn on a the pawn on A4
is not necessarily A Dangerous Pawn at
all so uh Bishop to A2 A3 F7 is still
under a lot of pressure but just simply
King G2 and then something very
beautiful that I noticed from the game
was this little king walk that way G had
with King to
F3 is pretty much getting the the the
king into the game and there's not much
that black can do about it right because
even if the King somehow you know he
wants
to let's say that it wants to get into 2
F7 uh you even have ideas of Rook E7 now
that the king is gone right so there's
there are just threats everywhere and
because the position is just so so
uncomfortable and none of the pieces
have active play for for
white um black ended up resigning here
so
obviously those were not uh all of the
games from from this round but in my
opinion they were the most exciting um
the I think also the game between uh
donchenko and Alesa was very interesting
um Alesa made like this I guess you
could call it a blunder but it was just
a very difficult position to to defend
and then at one point he just kind of
let
go and then the prag when June game was
also
um very interesting as well prag is on a
on an amazing um streak possible for you
to go into
theame I think we have run out of time
yeah we're actually a little bit over
time but
um obviously like all of the games are
very interesting and you can find um you
should be able to find like the games
annotated in different sites whether
it's chess space or chess.com
or whatever um yeah so overall the
tournament is I would say it's very
exciting as usual um I think there is a
four-way uh tie for first place right
now and it's exciting to see who's going
to come out on
top and yeah I'm sure we'll keep having
more exciting games on the rounds to
come but this is all I have for today so
yeah thank you so much for being here
are we yeah thank you um are we are we
ending the stream or no yeah just yeah
say bye okay byebye everyone
[Music]
and